hello rejects it's greg here it's john
here we're gonna talk about our top 10
most anticipated comic book movies from
twenty seventeen to twenty twenty this
is all subjective that's a lie it's all
objective yeah these are all gasp this
is facts we check them online check them
online we did our research we got a
marketing team together study thousands
of people can come and we came up with
our top ten so if you have like movies
on here that are not on our list you're
just flat-out wrong you're just wrong
that's the way it works we haven't
forgotten anything there's none zipping
all mathematically not an opinion based
thing it's all it's all about just facts
here we're dealing wits about us we
dictate you know the taste of society
and if you believe us good cuz that that
is your fault so that mean you're on
team right that's alright so for number
ten number ten ten we're putting on here
what some of you guys might consider
your number one and we'll go into why
this is number ten Avengers infinity
wars papar one and two together we're
don't have to do like part 1 party yeah
Avengers infinity war I'm really looking
forward to this film because I know the
Marvel films have greatly been building
up strictly to infinity war you know
like how phase one was building up to
the first Avengers ever since Avengers
they've been building up to infinity war
constantly referencing the Infinity
stones referencing fan house every once
in a while am I skeptical [ __ ] yeah I'm
scanning depending like this is so many
goddamn heroes like how that you watch
an x-men movie and you're like those too
many people why don't we imagine what
it's like with infinity war where you're
like but it's too many people and maybe
it'll be compact but I feel that like
what fans are probably gonna go for is
some killer action sequences yeah those
awesome sweeping circling shots aerial
shots of tracking shots coverage Robert
covered and kicking ass side by side
yeah look at them punching over there
look at them punching over there but
John brought up some good points like as
we were like really breaking down what
we wanted on our list cuz there's a lot
of comic book movies yeah that's a
wheeling hair down to 10 but can't go
into a little bit of why you were why
you've been a little hesitant about this
yeah there's the one we had to fight
about to be ligated what should be on
those lips this didn't originally make
my list just because like this is a
movie that to me I'm more interested in
seeing just because I know that it's all
been building to this so I'm like you
know because I've followed along this
long I'm interested in checking it out
but of all the movies we looked at that
are coming out and a lot of other stuff
grabbed me more like I'm looking forward
to more cuz the thing is we've done the
Avengers a few times at a great time
watching the second Avengers movie but
when I think back on it it's kind of a
mess to me and these movies keep getting
bigger and bigger and Marvel has a
villains problem and none of the Thanos
footage has really made me excited to
see Thanos it's not made me scared of
him in any way it could be anybody right
now I'm sure he'll get better as the
character unfolds on screen but because
all these movies have to be their
biggest battle yet and and all that
stuff like I've seen so many biggest
battles that I don't know if this one's
gonna live up to it for me cuz they're
all about huge and the thing is I know
people really love civil warrants the
same directors of Civil War and and and
winter soldier too but the thing is
those are personal and this doesn't feel
personal to me yeah it's more like let's
get as many heroes together because we
need to fight the baddest guy in this
part of the universe but we know that I
mean some of them might die I'm hoping
I'm hoping they kill off at least two or
three characters yeah they're hoping for
the movie they do because I'm like have
some [ __ ] balls come on and yeah you
want to prove that that like in part one
they gotta kill off someone it gotta
kill off someone in part two they gotta
kill up at least one more person I'm
hoping they do that yeah I mean I feel
like we all have end of the world
fatigue yeah when it comes out there
like [ __ ] these Marvel movies it's
just because we don't believe it we just
don't believe they'll actually ever lose
or something like we know how the
machines work too it's like these movies
are all contracted out so it's like you
know that because everything is a
franchise now certain things have to be
safe and we have to keep this thing go
these movies keep getting huger and
huger with their action pieces who
yeah you did and after a while it's like
the stuff that's worked for me recently
like the reason I like Deadpool so much
or certain other things or even
guardians of the galaxy was because at
the end of the day it was more about it
was more of a personal conflict you know
yeah looks related to the characters
themselves and it seems like if cramming
so many characters in like I know
they'll juggle them well enough i'm not
saying i don't think it'll be good for
what it is but just a mega battle i'm
not really that excited of that
especially having just seen Doctor
Strange was like all of space-time and
everything might just rip apart right
now only but we can reverse it yeah we
got one thing I brought with John and
we'll move on one day I brought it with
John was like well I kind of you like
the last harry potter movie the last
lord of the rings movie is that this is
supposed to be like big you know
celebrants all about spectacle and
celebrating the heroes uniting and
fighting the big bad guy taking him down
but he did bring up a good point Thanos
isn't as anticipated or built up in the
movies maybe if you're a comic book
lover you're really enthused for Thanos
but in the movies like look at it like
Harry Potter like you build up Voldemort
for all these [ __ ] movies and then
you're like all right this is the final
battle is the battle is gonna go down
finally Harry and Voldemort universe TJ
and like I don't really feel that by for
a person who's not that big into the
comics does really know much about
Thanos not really that excited about
that oh this is it like your life
wondering like what is the big deal I
feel like a lot of this stuff we've seen
is I just wish in hindsight that they
made some of these like stings and
little illusions a bit more interesting
or sinister because pretty much every
time I remember seeing Thanos it's just
some subject coming up to him like hey
the plan that we just did in this movie
that everybody just saw didn't work just
as carly's going in like maybe I should
just do I know and the other thing that
you brought up to which is good point is
that like those are the final harry
potter film the final Lord of the Rings
film like you we know that a large
amount of this is gonna still keep going
they got more film slated after yeah
anymore so this isn't like the Big Bang
glorious for raw the reason why we still
put this on this list as I am genuinely
looking forward to watching it I do just
want to see like oh I think it's cool
when you see all these characters on the
same screening of the film it's not that
great i'm still like it's cool you the
book we looked at all the movies that we
didn't include on this list and avengers
in any war was the one we were like like
we need a number 10 slot why don't we
look at what is the film that we're
definitely going to why I really like
well we're all we're definitely gonna
watch infinity Warner regardless this is
so we put that on this list the other
films we have a much more genuine
enthusiasm yeah yeah and I'm not not
excited for infinity ward it's something
I'm very familiar with and some of these
other ones or not no I guess been as
much time of the other ones I number
nine number nine guardians of the galaxy
volume dos first card is the galaxy was
a very exciting film a lot of fun
totally fresh flare different vibe and
something that we needed in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yeah a shot of sci-fi
in that space ha provide and it's not
about likes even though you got that us
and there they got Infinity stones it's
done in a way where you don't feel like
they're just trying to reference other
Marvel movies or the other Marvel worlds
and I it's nice and they're free to go
off and be a little more on their own
universe yeah and they work they work
which was great you know they're not
earth so yeah his graham and guards at
galaxy two what I really like about it
all these actors seems so excited to be
a part of it especially Vin Diesel this
group he's like yeah most of smoking
about how excited he's of you part it
really threw himself into these movie
and James Gunn I love that he went out
of his way to say like hey I know I
didn't do a great job with the villain
in the first one for him to acknowledge
that is saying like he's probably gonna
go out of his way to make sure he gives
us a great villain the second one yeah
her Russell thrown into the mix she's
like that's just like yeah I'm totally
on board for that I imagine will be a
scene stealer I think her Russell is one
of the best actors of all time that's
the primary reason I'm sold on it and
the fact that James Gunn's doing it
again James gonna never done a movie
like this not on the scale and it's not
an automatic reassurance that if a
director is returning that it's gonna be
great yeah of Ultron or spider-man 3 it
doesn't necessarily mean like oh it's
gonna be a damn good movie for sure I do
feel that James Gunn like he is one of
those like comic book kind of nerdy
directors who I feel really does love
guardians of the galaxy I don't know the
teaser trailers got me excited again it
just seems like a great continuation it
doesn't feel like it's just trying to
lead up to infinity war I get a little
bit more of like oh it's just the next
in an ongoing series of adventure
from from Guardian the at more so than
it's like oh the stakes leggins the
world might end tonight like that
franchise feels more like a comic book
to me cuz I'm just like what's gonna
happen to the next issue our number
eight is spider-man homecoming I'm
excited for this film I really did like
Tom Hollands portrayal and Captain
America Civil War Johnny they didn't see
it and you want to mention this video so
the world doesn't hate you but I'm
matching it anyway but you know everyone
loves a minute I'm excited for this
because yeah I think spider-man is that
character who does need to be a part of
the MCU I really like Sam rang his first
couple spider-man movies I even like
Andrew Garfield in the amazing
spider-man one I actually enjoy the
amazing spider-man 1 overall I don't
really think this is about like Sony
just [ __ ] up their movies I think that
is one of those things too who but i
think that spider-man is that character
beyond the x-men beyond fantastic for
who I'm like which one does need to be
in the Marvel properties in the films
and it's spider-man for me so I'm
excited that he's included it fits
perfectly in with the comic book
characters they've chosen to bring to
life the world they chosen to bring to
the film's I just have a lot of faith
that Marvel will probably nail this one
correctly I think so too and I mean I'm
excited to see that I'm excited to see
Spidey I'm expire man i'm excited to see
you spider-man return I mean Spiderman
was always my favorite growing up now
that we're into our third live action
franchise I'm a little just being
cautious cuz I'm like are they gonna
recapture that magic but you know from
all I've heard and seen about Tom
Holland he seems like good choice and
javis is an odd choice for directors I
am excited I feel like it's a really
good hands with Marvel so I definitely
want to check it out what I like to that
they said they're doing that the made
clear from the beginning is they're not
gonna be making it a origin stories
already spider-man just like how he is
and it's in civil war it's picking up
after the events of Civil War you're
gonna see who Peter Parker's at this
time and I think Tom Horn is perfectly
cast as the dude looks 15 I feelings
gonna look 15 for like the rest of his
life let's look at the guy you don't
have to worry about that thing that the
first spider-man did or amazing
spider-man said that we're gonna do but
by part 2 they're like we gotta get them
out of high school is look young I feel
like we're not gonna run into that
problem with this franchise and so it is
gonna be cool because Marc Webb said it
with amazing spider-man
wats has been saying about this film is
that some of the most interesting points
and Peter Parker's life are his time in
high school it feel like we're actually
going to be able to explore that this
time so I'm hoping this is a great
launching period for this John you
introduce number seven jesus is coming
in at number seven Aquaman James Wan's
Aquaman I'm just excited for that reason
man i'm just excited like a my light
yeah my students start uh James Wan is
one of those filmmakers were at least
right now like I kind of feel like he
knows how to do it even the weird
earthquake city that seems like it's
DC's movies right now I feel like he can
make something solid at least the
footage of Aquaman from the Justice
League trailer looked cool to me like
just their take on the character looked
cool I'm curious how glad Aquaman is
coming to the big screen actually like
that's a character it's been [ __ ] on a
lot of over so much time and I always
thought he was cool so I'm really a main
reason I want to see it is for James Wan
directing the film I feel like most of
his films are pretty damn good even if
you don't like some of them I think most
are very very good he's especially in
the jonathan and with furious 7 he
proved he can do these big blockbuster
films and make them work and add a
little something extra as well yeah
seems like he's good at taking whatever
he's given and making sure it's executed
well and also giving it some some person
I he always seems like he knows just
what he's doing and jason momoa first
thing I saw him in was the conan remake
which I did not like I actually turned
that off I was like I just can't sit
through this I don't like it at all I
didn't like him either I just finished
season to a game of thrones I finally
started watching the show I thought he
was great in it I thought he was
fantastic so it got me excited like uh
really says guys gonna be awful but now
it seems like he's gonna have that you
know he's obviously not pretty boy
blonde hair blue eye Aquaman orange
looking true so sexy yeah I think so
sexy and buff but he has more of that
like Valkyrie kind of look at me and I
think that will work as an Aquaman for
the universe DC is trying to establish
yeah he does look kind of on the right
level for what they're doing hey I saw
that video on the internet of Jason
Momoa like throwing an axe from crime
target
then drinking a beer and I was like yeah
I'll watch oh and like a savage
personality it seems like a soufflé yeah
like the guy should be playing a super
number six we have on the list as Wonder
Woman have been liking the footage you
even seen from Wonder Woman I know DC
hasn't been having the greatest
reputation I'd always make a good
trailer and there was a letter released
from that warbirds employees like don't
even get me started well we heard about
a wonder woman I still feel like from
watching the trailer there's gonna be
plenty to still admire about the film I
don't feel like it'll be a bland void of
life kind of movie you know like how
some people proceed Batman V Superman
and I feel like cuz Bambi Superman like
you can argue like there's a cool fight
scene there's some cool visuals but you
don't really walk away thinking about it
well if you're like you know you got
some great production design in there
like a lot of the costumes look great
it's a period piece so I feel there's
gonna be plenty to admire just in total
production design see I think that's
cool wishfully I hope they kind of keep
the Wonder Woman movies period for a
while that's when I missed with the
captain america like I I thought it was
so cool to go back oh man we're gonna
get Wonder Woman in Justice League I
like that it's a period piece I'm
excited for that and I'm excited you
know it's about time we had a movie
about a female superhero and its Wonder
Woman is is arguably like the female
superhero he's so like let's do it yes
pinus Steve Trevor looks like he's gonna
be pretty [ __ ] funny yeah and the
action does look really cool looks like
there's some really really cool action
sequences in there yeah I'm a little
worried about how the film's could be
told a little worried about the story
and all that [ __ ] because of what we see
from previous DC films I'm going in with
an open mind and I still feel like lay
up we put this you know number six
because I still feel like there's gonna
be enough to walk away from to be like
this stuff was definitely good though
yeah this stuff was still like you can't
argue that this stuff was cool i like
the people involved i like the idea and
I like that they're going out with the
Jean female super girly female director
that's really cool ladies can have
emails to love females yeah and black
people right yeah see those two everyone
was exciting man everyone
screw-on respects you again my sad I
like Nick jr. you say it just the way
you're saying like females blacks and
gays that's everyone right that's
everyone that encompasses then I'm the
most awesome humble human being in the
world and you're very conscious of the
people right can we change number five
for Deadpool two are you really excited
for Green Lantern Corps I'm more
interesting Green Lantern Corps but
really in Deadpool to look is already no
difficulty and Green Lantern Corps seems
like it's interesting to me like green
lantern corps is like ah this could is
because like I could take their universe
out in an odd direction you know they
[ __ ] it up the first time so I'm like
now they've got 300 course not just one
guy it's like a couple guys it's a new
universe and like okay cool yeah that
sounds great i'm just not that excited
well i just feel like DC the Green
Lantern was supposed to be the original
stark of the DCE you and they [ __ ] that
up and DCE you hasn't exactly been that
great so for them to be like we'll be
doing green land records I we haven't
even proving yourself with other movies
that you can read you Green Lantern
right this time that's a very fair and
Deb here to I'm like it just that sounds
really cool then pull together I great
let's keep this whole part of the video
I don't disagree it you never five or
ten full too yeah devil dude I mean how
can you not be excited for it other than
the fact that they're having to rector
issue you said all that but they got one
of the directors from John wick to come
on board and the one thing I I feel
about Deadpool that could be improved
yeah what's the action sequences I'm
like I like that Ryan rels like I don't
want to make it go huge I don't want to
make you go crazy I don't like I know
that's part of the charm is keeping it
like a little smaller John wick is not a
huge film yeah you know it's made for 40
million dollars or something and it is
super stylistic in its action it's
beautifully shot you because we're gonna
want like give us more humor you give us
all breaking the forefoot whatever that
[ __ ] is I feel like the one thing they
could do is give us cooler action
sequences yeah I mean it seems like he
has the the tool to kind of fill in what
you might have been missing from
Deadpool cuz denfeld Deadpool does at
least to me when I think about it it
feels kind of like a little movie yeah
in a way like it's still you know
superhero movie
so crazy but it doesn't seem overly huge
and John wick does seem huge even though
he only goes a few places yeah some guy
who can make this feel sufficiently big
without it having to be yeah like huge
is yeah I'm excited to see what he does
without i'm curious as to how this guy
does humor now I think it'd be cool to
see Deadpool use more gonna he mainly
use like his blades and his swords and
the first movie so I think it'd be cool
is like let's see some that John wick
kind of gun action and a Deadpool like
that and like make it even more surreal
maybe more more crazy because you're not
dealing with it just a human being right
now you know if a John wick director met
and discussed with the powers that be
and they're like yeah let's go with this
guy the first one was good enough that i
trust that that's probably gonna work
out you know yeah like I'm a little
concerned for their for their you know
conflict with the second one but I have
no reason yet to be like oh it's trouble
number four is lack Panther yeah
chadwick boseman is really cool and
Captain America Civil War and I think I
Ryan Coogler I got it like a huge black
cast in the zone like I said ma'am
females and blacks where's her gay
superhero Black Panther was a really
cool character that you know one thing
that Civil War did really well with that
film was they introduced black panther
and they managed to still make him shine
and in a movie where a lot of characters
have to shine yeah and it gets you
excited for Black Panthers is more of a
serious kind of character and I imagine
this is gonna be more of a serious kind
of Marvel movie which I'm okay with a
lot of these marathons are jam-packed
with humor and I feel like this one will
have much more serious vibes or young
Ryan Coogler did like creed and
fruitvale station he's proved himself to
be an awesome director hasn't tackled
something this big before feel like
you'll know what to do with the material
I trust in the filmmakers I trust in the
cast I trusted marvel I feel like this
will be a really great addition and
something different and more risky to
put out there yeah definitely i'm
excited for this movie and i'm excited
that this is happening cuz it seems like
we're living in a time now we're more
you know diverse shows and movies are
coming out iversity man i'm excited to
see the this is the the biggest stage we
have right now in into you know North
American cinema I'm excited just for
what this movie is but also you know
everything I've seen a black panther you
looks [ __ ] awesome you know and I'm
ready for super hero movies to become
more than just cool and it seems like
you know a Black Panther movie is a good
way to kind of address some things and
to at least make some allegories while
we're having fun number three is justice
league dark Justice League dark I'm not
gonna lie I don't know much about
justice league dark characters but it
does sound like an intriguing kind of
world for me because they deal more with
like magic in that world one thing that
r is really intriguing to me is I got
doug liman to do it yeah doug liman he's
you know if I was on movie fights I'd be
like doug liman to jumper and that was
that great other than that yes it did
edge of tomorrow he did edge it tomorrow
which was awesome he launched the bourne
franchise brand it's not the best one
out of them but it still is the one that
launched it and he said somebody like
really enjoyable mr mrs smith i think is
a total great time and you tomorrow was
my favorite movie that year it came out
that was that Sammy's one of Tom
Cruise's best films and Doug Lyman's
best film to me is edge of tomorrow so
he shown that like whatever you thought
a jumper if you thought I just don't
care whatever edit tomorrow is another
huge spectacle film that he totally
nailed and got it down just writing that
is also a comic book adaptation so I
feel like justice league dark dealing
with bunch of weird kind of [ __ ] and
then superheroes I feel like my horror
elements and stuff and I feel like doug
liman knows how to cast his movies well
yeah I feel like he really knows what
actors to hire for roles I feel like
you'll he'll probably put together a
really entertain you feel because
regardless of his films lack in certain
awesome depth sometimes I feel like he
knows how to make a really entertaining
film well this is a movie that excites
me because a it's a little further out
in in DC's slate and I feel like by this
time they can probably you know sort out
whatever kinks still remain I hope I
read a blurb just somewhere where Doug
Liman was interviewed and he said like
they asked me to get weirder and more
doug liman e on this move ice and i was
just like yeah awesome like I don't
alarm to the lyman a yeah I'm a little
lime zest on lemon zest so DC producers
just talking like I get it guys lime I
get it to you
yeah I'm excited this sounds like coolin
out there and you know just a little a
little different from the stuff we
usually see number DOS is thor ragnarok
how can you not be excited for this
after seeing that promo vid they
released thor ragnarok is this is
probably the most excited I've been
about a Thor movie this is the most
exciting anyone's [ __ ] I mean one of
the biggest patient's of it is that they
are like the Hulk will be featured a lot
in it which i think is cool I feel like
Thor and Hulk if you're gonna take one
of the Marvel characters and throw the
mana and one in the Thor movie it is
gonna be hoped that would make it for
the most interesting kind of film
they're on a level where they could be
an odd couples oh yeah they definitely
definitely Chris Hemsworth I really
enjoyed and this director you know John
show me where the shadows heat seems
like a fantastic director who will know
how to provide personality and humor and
provide weirdness to this yeah I don't
know much about Who Ragnarok is I don't
know much about what the actual plot
developments are all I know is the
people involved getting Hulk in there
that sounds like it's gonna be one hell
of a worthwhile time and people are very
excited for it and actually can't wait
to see a trailer for this movie yeah
totally and I mean I'm always a little
concerned when they when they pluck
these guys who are great at making indie
films out to make a giant movie like
this but that that sketch that you
showed me that made me laugh a lot of
times and it seemed like they were
having fun with it and embracing some of
tyco YTD sensibilities and from looking
back at just I've looked over his
filmography and like pretty much
everything he's done is has been met
with great praeis this seems like
another guy who just knows how to make a
movie and so I'm really excited for what
he brings to this and this seems like an
interesting choice in a fresh direction
and I don't know how much of that comedy
will be you know in the DNA of the move
I don't think it will but I think it
will something tells me that they will
embrace that you know have it Hulk in it
i really like a mark ruffalo yeah tired
guys Hulk I've seen the logo and the
logo with that like weird 80s shutter
effect them like but there it seems like
they're having fun I feel like they're
doing their best to make this one
distinct cuz the other tooth or movies
Logan Logan I I'm really surprised that
Dyke is technically an x-men film in its
own way it just looks the most different
yet the
most appealing yeah like it's like whoa
this is drastically taking a dark gloomy
turn but it's also like an awesome
Western and it looks gritty and I love
it that are going with the r-rating what
I was hearing the director talked about
sharing hugh jackman talk about then
seeing the photos stills was like this
is I gonna be cool yeah and then I saw
the trailer and I'm like I I'm it's
easily the most anticipated film out of
any comic book movie ever heard of so
far it's a source grounded looks
personal looks like it's gonna be a
great send-off for Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine it's risky like you just I
don't think that I don't think of what
x-men was part of the MCU you would get
Logan yeah you know that's and I love
when they do this kind of stuff it seems
like it really is about Logan yes like
most everything will tie into him this
will be a it seems like a personal movie
yeah not just like oh there's a villain
but it seems like a really personal
movie that's going all in on this really
sparse hot you know desolate western
style and I think that's really cool it
feels more like a film than a than just
you know a comic-book movie and for them
to like go into the future while you're
also continuing with the cast of people
from like x-men apocalypse and [ __ ] with
their films yeah when you're like well
here's what it or the futures head is it
a lot of the mutants are dining out and
there's barely anyone left it's such a
risky type of thing for a film to do not
a for a comic book to do but the comic
book is also very much beloved and I
hear they're doing their best to really
honor the old man Logan comic yeah and
that's the stuff I'm curious about for
this movie because there are a couple
money shot that's what I want to know is
how much of that sort of money shot
stuff seep soon because as I understand
it old man Logan there's a lot about the
stigma of his claws yeah and the and
also just the sheer pain of it you know
now his regeneration is going no it kind
of looks like an interesting like
Western character study pot elliptic it
yeah it just looks so different and I I
love it I love everything I've seen so
far I'm really hoping it delivers this
feels like a very fantastic fitting
send-off they can name
yeah exactly I hope he dies I do I hope
he actually dies in this one yeah give
the boy some peace let him rest Missy
alright guys well we didn't include
Justice League the flash valerian in the
city of a thousand planets captain
marvel gambit and Green Lantern Corps
I'm sure some of you are gonna comment
and like where's this Megan booby on the
lush lashes on it's like 10th director
like I don't know yeah Zack Snyder
hasn't exactly proven himself the lair
in the city of a thousand planets lupe
songs very hit and miss we also don't
know much about Captain Marvel yes
excited that it's happening gambit jizz
losses director just sleep dark yeah and
Green Lantern Corps you heard our
explanation as to why we bump that off
the list and I know there's probably
some other films like animated movies
and [ __ ] coming out but yeah those are
our top 10 what are your top 10 you're
looking forward to it so good YouTube
question keeps me interactive what are
your top 10 all right females blacks and
gays if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe today John is reason scary
instagram and twitter and he is also the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash blue house and facebook.com slash
the real rejects and I want to get a
shout out to jared leto I don't know
what's happening with your career right
now it's Joker my friend they released
like footage this one got put together
supercut of like behind the scenes
footage at they release of the movie oh
no and like other excerpts from the
trailer showing like why we're in any of
these things included the extended cut
showing the Joker literally had a lot
more scenes I just feel like Warner
Brothers is just trying to make us
forget about your life so they could
desire one day guys come on let's put
the [ __ ] back in the movie